dans notre pays cette tempête accentue
la pollution du littoral atlantique ce
matin au croisic la population
désemparée découvrez les plages maculées
du fuel échappée de l'erika fabrice
turpin nadine picard tôt ce matin les
habitants du croisic n'ont pu que
constater l'étendue des dégâts
les nappes de pétrole qui se sont
échappées de l'erika avait tout saccagé
pendant la nuit du croisic jusqu'à la
baule toute la côte sauvage plage
fallait strict était recouverte d'un
épais tapis marron noir gluant et
nauséabond nuage il passa du coup j'ai
un copain qui m'a dit qu'elle va sur mer
le petit port c'était une flaque de
pétrole
je suis venu voir par curiosité puis
souvent possible pour ses 26 pokémon
éleveurs et bat pas du tout quand je
vois ça j'ai pas de mots pour nous
exprimer ça c est ce que vous voulez
c'est comme ça on pourra bien faire avec
avec
le premier sentiment d'impuissance passé
ils ont pris leur propre matériel pelle
ciré bottes râteau tout ce qui leur
tombait sous la main pour tenter de
retrouver le visage originel de leur
littoral et moyens ils sont bien
organisés ici où c'est la débandade
on peut avec m'appelle comme ça c'est la
plage tout meurt il était en bronze leur
repas pendant ce temps du mazout la
marée noire ne fait en fait que
commencer une multitude de nab de 10 15
20 mètres de diamètre ont été repérés
sur plus de 20 km à quelques milles de
la pointe du croisiens du tout ces
quelques nappes quelques petites
galettes de fioul c'est pas une
catastrophe écologique
voilà vingt goaler garder le résultat
dominique voynet justement elle était
aujourd'hui partout en vendée en loire
atlantique
histoire de faire oublier la polémique
de ces derniers jours c'est pas ça une
catastrophe écologique madame voynet qui
est il contraire
oui et non les antennes hier vous ne
parlez pas de catastrophe écologique g10
lumière quatre vents que la pollution
sera rivé sur les plages on pouvait pas
prédire en dire de façon précise
l'étendue et la gravité donc quelques
heures plus tard c'est évident c'est une
catastrophe écologique de grande ampleur
mais ce n'est pas comme certains me
pressaient de le dire hier la
catastrophe du siècle
il sera toutefois très difficile de
convaincre les habitants de piriac de la
turballe et du croisic et de la baule
car ce soir ils savent que le pire est
encore à venir et l'image de marque de
la côte atlantique vient d'en prendre un
coup certains parlent de saison
complètement gâché ce soir ils n'ont
qu'une seule idée en tête
le pétrolier total fina doit payer et
après